foreign  money  um  and here come his family behind him that  is his daughter  hannah and son-in-law colin and his  grandchildren  benji and georgia as well couldn't quite  hear  what the monarch was saying to him there  it sounded like she was saying what an  amazing  amount of money you have raised i also  understand that she has said to him  uh the 94 year old monarch there said to  recently turned 100 sir tom  moore 100 is such a wonderful  age and the ceremony continues now that  sword incidentally  uh belonging to the queen's father  king george vi uh remember that uh  certain more as he is now propelled into  national fame after raising 33  million pounds for the nhs he walked 100  laps  with that walking frame that we could  see him using to advance there across  the lawn  towards the queen for the investiture  ceremony there